as a script doctor how many times will
you reread a script before you start
rewriting it oh that's
interesting well first obviously like
the cold read and then you know I do all
of the sets of notes but I actually like
to go sort of in stages so I don't know
if I would say I read it and reread it
many times before I start but I work in
little stages so let's say I get the
script right right I do my set of notes
I have a conversation with the writer
the producer and how we're going to
tackle the doctoring of the script and
then I would do a first pass on the
script that for example just tackles
formatting and things like that so I'm
familiarizing myself with the raw file
in a way it's sort of this dance where
I'm like okay I'm putting my fingers you
know to work on this script and I just
fix like the little things and then I do
a second pass you know where I'm
focusing on the characters and then I'm
changing things around and moving or and
then I work you know with the structure
and things like that so in a sense I'm
reading it multiple times but at the
same time I'm tackling things I don't
think I just read it multiple times
before I just have conversations about
it to a point where I'm like okay I
think like I understand this script so I
talk to the writer the producer and
we're so ins sync that I'm kind of
dreaming about this script before I
actually put my hands to it
how do you determine what parts of the
screenplay need the most
attention I think that the first thing
for me it's always character that's
where I usually start because I feel
like character especially the
protagonist determines absolutely
everything about the script I think that
character relates to the structure in a
way that writers a lot of times forget
and I would say that that's one of the
things that I Focus the most about when
I'm analyzing a script uh that your
protagonist has a goal and they have you
know a want they have a core wound they
should have an arc in the movie right or
the TV pilot whatever it is you're
trying to tell and all of that needs to
be linked with the structure so I think
that that's one of the first things I
focus on when I'm analyzing something
every turning point of the story needs
to be connected to that emotional art
and that emotional journey of your
protagonist uh if you're writing a pilot
Every Act out should relate to that
emotional Arc if you're writing a
feature every Turning Point into the
different Acts or the midpoint should
relate to that emotional Arc so that's
one of the first things I look at when
I'm looking at a story because more
times than not if the story is not
working properly it is because the
structure is not there and by that I'm
not saying you have to follow you know a
path it's not like uh Pain by numbers
you know it's not like oh you have to do
this at every minute or Every Act has to
be at this page count that's not what
I'm saying and you can follow whatever
path you like some people like the three
structure some people like the eight
sequence approach some people like save
the cat you know here's Journey whatever
it is you're following audiences still
expect turning points right we all have
expectations we all still kind of think
in the three acts from Aristotle's
Poetics you it comes from then so there
are expectations that the audience has
so you want you know to follow someone's
journey and you want to see someone
change through the course of the story
so for me that's the first thing I
always focus on uh when I'm working on a
story if there's something that's not
that's not working I look at the
protagonist I look at the structure I
look at how their journey is going and
that's the one of the first things
obviously sometimes you're doctoring a
script and you know the arc is working
but maybe it's just a dialogue that you
need to tackle or sometimes you just
need to do polishes on some minor
characters but more times than not it's
that main structural issue that you're
kind of tackling if you had a chance is
there one movie that is almost perfect
that you would have if you had a chance
to come in and maybe give notes on the
script you would have changed a few
things oh that's an interesting question
I wish I could have you know endless
amounts of time to think of like the
perfect movie or TV show that I would
like to change you know
uh
but let me think I think that you know
When Harry Met Sally which is one of my
alltime favorite movies I think that
there's a few things I would change and
perhaps it's also the fact that so much
time has gone by you know it's older
movie uh we hope hopefully by now see
women different in movies so I would
maybe update that that would be kind of
like a dream job if I could do something
like that you know uh I don't like that
Meg Ryan is just kind of seen as this
more hysterical woman in a way like I
like the contrast you know that's one of
the greatest things about that movie
Sally Albright and Harry Burns literally
their last names tell tell you
everything you need to know about who
they are but I feel like she could have
been like more Old Bright but not
exactly just like more the historical
woman I would have loved to bring her
down a notch in that sense and kind of
make her not just all about the guy you
know and she's the one that kind of like
Falls for him and he's not seeing it I
would love to a little bit more you know
give her more depth to her character I
think that's what I would have tackled
in that movie but again I think it's one
of my favorite movies of all the time
but that would be kind of like a dream
doctoring job I would say say so maybe
give her I don't know if backbone would
be the right word but maybe have it
where her goal was not just to sort of
be chosen by someone yes like that's the
thing you know she has her two best
friends and they have this conversation
one time when they're having lunch you
know and one of them like brings out
like like rotary you know like the old
time me with like all of the guys like
you could be dating now or something you
know and they're talking about like oh
I'm 32 oh your clock doesn't start
ticking till you're you know they have
all of this conversations that maybe
back then you know they were like that
and that's what a lot of people were
seeing women wanted but I would love to
update that a little bit and not just
make her about like the guy the guy the
guy and like your clock is sticking and
you need to have the baby and this and
this and be married by a certain age I
would like to update that and I think
that that would be actually a great take
on an idea if someone is writing out
there sort of like a modern version of
what that movie was you know when har
mid Sally such a classic and I don't
think something like that has been done
in since the 80s when the movie came up
you know something like that with a more
updated view on how we see women because
this is kind of like going to another
tangent but one of the issues I tend to
see a lot when I'm doctoring scripts and
one of the things I always point out is
that the female characters are not
fleshed out enough and that's one of my
biggest pet peeves I see I read so many
great scripts where they just forget
that women are three-dimensional
characters and they just include them in
the story because oh we need to add some
females into the story we want to see
three-dimensional women we want to see
powerful interesting protagonist and sad
characters and not just oh the love
interest that is just boring and just
standing there you know so one of the
things I always say it's like yes you
can be writing this runchy maleb comedy
and you're trying to add this female
character but give them some dep don't
just like put the
object of attention there without giving
them something more so if I'm doctoring
something those are the types of things
that I'm focusing on with female
characters yeah I'm a broken record with
this but I know Margaret Atwood always
talks about how we tend to also make
women to good or or and the women are
human and so they're on different
spectrums of good and bad and so more
layered and that's the thing about
characters I like layered characters
that are realistic it's a sem with
antagonists and I always like to say
that antagonist should be the heroes of
their own stories they should be equally
interesting exciting and layered as the
protagonist that's what makes a good
antagonist if we can put ourselves in
their shoes and understand things from
their perspective and if we wearing
their shoes we might do things that way
that's what makes them Rich that what
what's makes you know want to watch a
movie because if they're boring layered
onedimensional
then you don't fear for your protagonist
you don't see where the risk is you
don't see where the issues are you're
just like oh my protagonist is going to
win because this person is just lame and
boring but no if you make them
threedimensional and not just the
stereotype of what a bad guy should look
like kind of like put yourselves in
yourself in their shoes make them liar
make them interesting make them real
people not just like evil for the sake
of being evil I hate that Trope when
like the antagonist has to be evil
because they're just evil
like especially when I'm reading you
know action pieces or Thrillers a lot of
the times the antagonists are just bad
guys for the sake of being bad I I I if
we're writing a really good movie and
you want that to be a memorable movie
keep them reasoning give them something
more why they're doing why they're what
they're
doing